thank you christian optum care breast
care the sponsors of this next segment
want to remind you how important it is
to get your proper breast screenings
done they have a special program that is
going to help and certified by the
national consortium of breast centers
and helps women navigate their health
care journey both physically and
emotionally hear how here's how it works
mary welcome to the show
thank you so much it's great to be here
thank you for everything you do for the
community we're talking about breast
care and breast cancer so let's just
start with breast cancer basics and what
it means
absolutely so breast cancer is such an
important issue for women it is actually
the most common kind of cancer that we
see in women no matter your race or your
background or ethnicity as a matter of
fact in nevada it is estimated that over
2 300 cases of cancer breast cancer
cases will be diagnosed this year
wow so that means we need to be getting
our screenings correct
absolutely so it is imperative that
women get their annual breast cancer
screening through mammograms
although breast cancer cannot be
prevented it helps us if we screen and
detect breast cancer at early stages so
that we're able to treat it
appropriately absolutely preventative
care is so important i'm so can you
break down can you break down what a
mammogram is what are the basics of that
process
absolutely so mammogram is an x-ray of
the breast so basically a woman comes in
and we we take uh their breasts and put
it on this plate and we
women call squishing the breast and just
trying to get
findings of anything that may be
abnormal in the breast for us to
identify and quickly get the women
treated
and what about the management programs
that you guys provide
breast care management takes different
approaches we do have a
multi-disciplinary team approach here at
upton breast cancer
care center and it is just for us to
work together
so that we're able to identify the
the abnormal
issues in the breast and quickly get the
woman treated with our team of experts
that we work together with wow okay well
thank you so much mary we appreciate you
and everything awesome care does for the
community
thank you so much we appreciate you
thank you optim care breast care for
sponsoring this segment they have
locations across southern nevada for
more information call 702-724-8787
or visit optumcare.comcancercare